[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it okay I can't contain it I am
so excited about today's review I can't
believe we're looking over it for the
first time ever we are going to review
Samurai Jack I'm not right set by many
to be one of the best cartoons ever made
Samurai Jack hypnotize an entire
generation with its stylized animation
surreal humor and dramatic turns I can't
believe we get to look over it today
greatest job in the world
so let's whip out our katana blades and
get ready for action for the first time
ever this is well that's fine too
because Jerry Bruckheimer got tired of
torturing his adult audiences he finally
said hey why don't we mentally scar our
children as well released in 2003 this
film started off as a mafia comedy
geared more towards adults the studio
agreed it wasn't funny enough though so
they drew inspiration from one of the
highest comedic bars at the time that's
no dogs
oh you think I'm kidding I'm not kidding
producers were so impressed by the
marketing campaign for snow dogs that
they turned this into a family-friendly
animal picture so not only do you have
an unfunny mafia comedy but you also
have an unfunny animal picture both
almost in no way connecting with each
other at all
it apparently worked though as not only
was this number one at the box office on
Martin Luther King jr. weekend but it
even spawned an animated sequel kangaroo
jack g'day USA
Oh so how long comfortable is all this I
refer you back to partnership let's take
a look at knots am i right jack but
kangaroo jack we open with a flashback
of our main character Charlie whose mom
begins to date Christopher Walken okay I
will give this movie a chance if at some
point he says this is not all the tech
gurus he also meets his best friend Luis
who saves him from drowning in the water
oh I didn't add in that music by the way
that is from the movie you get it
because he's not Superman they're
playing Superman I'm gonna stop with
that I just had to get one more out
katti years later we're walking is the
stepdaddy charlie now played by Jerry
O'Connell I'd pay good money if this was
a slider reality who works under walking
and is still friends with Lewis play now
by Anthony Anderson she's still getting
him into trouble because your kid
doesn't know how to drag you to good
movies yet trying to get these TVs off
the truck man I don't get paid I need
your help on this one
two hours tops that's all I need this is
really important blah blah blah
something now result in a Bruckheimer
chase again this is shot a little
differently for a goofy animal movie
isn't it
kangaroo jack not enemy of the state
they get away but not from the wrath of
Walken and if there is a God please have
this be the awkward walking who gets a
laugh like on SNL and not the awkward
walking who makes things stiff and
uncomfortable like on SNL Louis Booker
you degenerate moron a little bit Bob
I'll take it you would I have no doubt
slay them maiden and save the dragon
okay ten bucks right now he got that
line wrong and they tapped it anyway a
lion can raise a mouse but the mouse is
still a mouse I knew two mice they fell
into a bucket of cream and just when you
think it couldn't get any goofy or high
Michael Shannon not look in that
envelope under any circumstances
understood I swear this whole scene is
just walking in Shannon trying to out
walk in and Shannon themselves do you
meet a man named mr. Smith you give this
envelope to mr. Smith
not bad huh I really got the weird dead
stare down yes but I have this dead
stare with the finger thing you can't
beat my dead stare I'm still doing the
finger thing sanely that's the last of
the accidental happiness as the two of
them are sent to drop off money in
Australia but look they both try
fireball candy because I don't know why
is my mouth on fire huh something wrong
with this stop acting like a baby huh we
forget to add a punch line to this Oh
I'll get used to that kangaroo jack but
Lois discovers 50 grand in the envelope
and they decide to try and keep it but
not before some literal bathroom humor
something doesn't smell right here look
at it I've never seen so much green in
one little brown package oh it slipped
out we're here awhile folks so we scoop
it up oh this is one big load what a
mess when I roll around in it
hand me the rest of the pile what what's
the writing process for this like you
think they were proud of when they came
up with this nugget of genius gonna hold
it no don't put in the envelope I'm
gonna put it in my pocket
no there's something here I just can't
crack it well you're the writer of
Kramer vs Kramer trying to tell him to
godfather I'm sure you can think of
something my god I think I've got it
what is it what if while in the bathroom
instead of talking about money the
people outside think they're talking
about
[Music]
at least smell it maybe later no no
that's Bruckheimer and vision making and
even stephen's kid a millionaire with
that one phrase thank God it had no
negative impact on him boycott that's a
lot of mug shots the key is to act like
you don't have anything to hide written
by a person who has clearly never gone
through customs yet I forget to mention
there's a lot of annoying editing in
this movie swipe swipe zoom in zoom outs
I'm not against fast editing if it's
done correctly and go right for example
uses fast editing to make the pacing
feel more exciting and flow faster this
best editing somehow feels dull and much
slower how is it doing that it's like a
time machine of mediocrity
what's that 2 seconds or 2 hours there
it's really hard to tell hey this still
might have the right idea it killed King
rujak before we even saw him just like
the initial trailer reactions hey I got
an idea
let's make our main characters kind of
weird and sick say cheese Christmas card
next let's find his family and do a
puppet show with his corpse but of
course the kangaroo is not dead and
somehow looks even faker than ice tea
and tanker I'm just imitating what we're
not hearing from the crowd right now Bob
Lewis realizes the money was in the
hoodie I put the coat on her so they
tried to chase after and seeing if they
can get it back shit this is the movie
isn't it the rest of the film is just
them chasing this damn thing
okay at the most this could pass for a
Sylvester and kangaroo short the filler
rod mackensen directed when he was
clearly focusing on phone corn Leghorn
cartoons but nope we got an hour 20 of
this hell the least he could have done
this turn this into a wily coyote
crossover they chase him for a while to
find no luck so they stop off at a bar
there they yanked of them drink that's
around here call me the stereotype they
get a plan mode I asked a wildlife
expert who of course happens to be
American hot clean as hell and in a
Bruckheimer film played by Estella
Warren see I put my lucky jacket on the
back of a dead kangaroo who came to life
and then hopped off with all my money
okay where's my agent Howard
speaking of which remember how this was
shoehorn to be called kangaroo jack
matter got to him doing something we
justified the tie low and to the credit
they do talk about him once tranquilizer
dart it works in three stages
Stage one temporary blindness Stage two
partial paralysis in stage three
complete shutdown of all motor skills
also the stages of watching this movie
there's this American girl that works
there and she is she has tense Christ
but walking discovers the guys are
missing and sends Chenin in to find them
maybe they'd figure they know my stuff
someone couldn't figure out she's
sandwich if they spotted him the pump
addicted on a proven all I think all of
walk-ins dialog was comprised of dares
to see if he'd actually say it after
Joey clams got away his head was some
office on the side note yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum you know
they asked the stereotype to fly them
towards the kangaroo but they
accidentally tranquilize the pilot they
crash on the ground and decide to walk
on foot where they come across a
sandstorm
you may think that's not funny but
you're wrong it's funny they start
seeing mirages though that's not playing
with their minds booths wait a second
I've have it another one of those
mirages and this one's a beauty yeah but
this one's definitely not real
Estelle Warren is pertained to be a
wildlife expert riding through the
desert without one speck of sand on her
is her acting good yes definitely not
her how you doing good
you good did I mention a good day USA he
also directs his own movie so many
different similarities between these two
and no joke immediately after groping
her we cut to the kangaroo rapping nice
you can talk I said they hit pop the
hippy they hit me to the hit pop you
don't stop the rock through the bangbang
boys because again your five-year-old
should really connect these two scenes
together
I'm just glad when they were wind it
back to watch the scene again they'll
always see this right before it Thanks
family-friendly Bruckheimer you'll be
happy to know this is hell soundtrack
24/7 I know I got a copy right here it's
literally just that over and over and
over as if that wasn't enough nightmare
for you well how about Christopher
Walken's voice coming out on a thing if
I find out one Charlie that you lost my
money I asked you to do something for me
this is not that this was the moment
when parents were checking their popcorn
to make sure it wasn't laced with
ecstasy still not freaky enough how
about we just randomly have them chant
chicken blood
oh yeah that's a thing chicken blood
chicken blood boy chicken blood I
consider myself a reasonably strong
person but I'm not gonna lie
kangaroos waving their fingers chanting
chicken blood is kind of freaking me I
don't know who was beaten as a child to
bring this scene to us but it's breaking
me
chicken online okay I think I need a
break to remind myself with species I am
please excuse me while I go and swim in
a puddle of my own tears
[Applause]
you
[Music]
so what's revealed that this nightmare
feel is actually a nightmare but that
won't stop advertisers from putting it
in every trailer making every kid think
it's about a wrapping kangaroo
he didn't stop the rock boys please what
do you think this is the Titanic drink
this it'll bring down the swelling
unfortunately it'll also make your
testicles fall off did I also mention he
goes waterskiing jump really fun for all
no cock very funny can't be too careful
that's right boys watching you grab a
woman's breasts they'll totally have a
good sense of humor about it if they're
fairly back about that kind of stuff but
I know what you're thinking nothing
could possibly top the bathroom scene
from earlier well I'm happy to say we
get to witness the pure genius of
Campbell farting oh you think I'm joking
you don't think I make that up play that
shit boys camels do that and again we're
here for a while folks
[Music]
you know somewhere a kid is watching
inside out for the first time right now
one unlucky son of a bitch
we have farting travels emotional
development intellectual understanding
great humor no farting camels we cracked
we know what's good for your kid thy
name its farting camels please do not
thank us
let your summer schools do that we're
giving them a lot of business they do
finally come across the kangaroo but
Warren insists they need to disguise
themselves to hide their scent
thank God kangaroos can't smell stupid
but fire ants munch on Lewis because you
know this movie didn't have enough
annoying sounds a dingo ate his funny
well at least this leads to a
family-friendly shower scene I was gonna
take a bath come near me I'll kill you
so nervous you had absolutely no effect
on me you could kiss me right now it
would make a slice
remember kids assertiveness force no
difference nothing
sorry well we literally met by you
grabbing my tits and you're ignoring my
threats of violence against you but like
most of the jokes in this movie she was
just playing hard-to-get however things
take a serious turn when the gangsters
catch them now there are two ways of
doing this and one of them is a lot less
painful than the other one is
fast-forwarding the movie the other is
letting it play out you can guess which
one is which they escape the leading to
kangaroo jack insert number 20 Oh huh
funny how no people are in that scene
almost like it was added after they
realized they weren't making a real film
which is a shame I was really curious
about the Joker and Harley scenes they
rescue Warren by making a threat that
honestly yeah I don't fully follow what
do you do for a living that makes you so
brave
Charlie I'm a hairdresser now drop the
knife why did that work do they think he
has scissor hands
but Michael Shannon arrives to make
things even more complicated
sounds very disappointing to hear you
lost that much we'll get the money back
it's too late for that Charlie
we had a contract and it didn't involve
my bloody Road I had to come all the way
down here to the sphincter of the galaxy
straighten out this puked-up furball of
a mess do not agitate me we had a
country not agitate me okay I am 100%
convinced they did not tell them the
name of this movie
they were probably told it was called
death down under or a devil in the
outback if they were told this movie was
called kangaroo jack they'd be like no
shit I mean I can just do this then
right right
but the kangaroo does show up resulting
in a wild brood chase
[Music]
this will have a slight redemption if it
goes to Thelma and Louise route Charlie
saves him from the fake backdrops but
Shannon gets the drop on them revealing
the real reason why they were dropping
off the money what do you think he was
paying Smith 50 grand for I mean we
traveled halfway across the world to pay
for our own execution pretty clever eh
super clever you know how many times
they used to do that in Sopranos
Australia assassination they used to
call this overused prize they couldn't
hear that
the cops are Russian and the Lewis is
blown away that Charlie saved his life
so now we're even you don't owe me any
more you rid of me are you talking about
I'm rid of you come on Charlie guilt was
the glue that held this friendship
together it is the only way we kept the
crew on this movie
you're wrong Lois I've always needed you
I need someone to share the shame on
this picture oh and look kangaroo jack
has a family they're gonna make the most
beautiful wallets yes because even the
movie has to remind itself it's called
kangaroo jack
no no it verbalizes that wait a minute
the movies called kangaroo jack it
should end with me and I can do
impersonations come on people
throw me a frickin bone come from me
Jesus that's all well I'll give that
ending this it makes target practice a
lot easier this movie was awful it was
clearly a bad things laughably turned
into an even worse thing a part of me
wishes they'd stuck with the original
version Oh apart all of me wishes they'd
stuck with the original version I'm sure
was bad but at least a head walking and
Shannon honking it up a bit this movie
as is just hurts it was dumb it was
painful it was a big pile of kangaroo
duck hop as far away from this as
possible well thank God the next big
review I'm gonna do is of a much better
movie The Green Mile that's right one of
Stephen King's best films I gotta admit
I was a little confused when I heard
that right
Reynolds was in it and they plays a
superhero with some type I don't
understand that part myself but what are
you gonna do so get ready for
[Music]
[Applause]
chicken blood she came back shaking a
lot
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shot on this week we are doing the best
friends Animal Society this is the only
national animal welfare organization
dedicated to ending the killing of dogs
and cats in America shelters a leader in
the no-kill movement best friends runs
life-saving programs in partnership with
more than 1,900 rescue groups and
shelters across the country as well as
regional centers in New York City Los
Angeles Atlanta and Salt Lake City and
the nation's largest no-kill sanctuary
for companion animals founded in 1984
best friends has helped reduce the
number of animals killed in shelters
nationwide from 17 million per year to 2
million per year as amazing as that is
that still means there's nearly 5,500
dogs and cats killed every day in
shelters just because they don't have
safe places to call home
this organization is determined to get
that number to zero by the year 2025 and
you can help if you look at their site
and their YouTube page you can not only
see all the great work that they do but
also the incredible animals that you
could help save click on the link and
see how you can save the life of one of
these amazing creatures
[Music]
you